Now, that we've created this user.
Let's go ahead and
connect to our server as that user.
I've opened a new terminal here, and
this terminal is on my local machine.
I have not connected to the server yet.
I can connect to the server using this
command, ssh student@127.0.0.1 -p 2222.
Let's break this command
down a little bit.
We've been connecting to our
server using vagrant SSHwhich
is just a shortcut for all of this.
SSH is the application we use to
remotely connect to the server.
And 127.0.0.1 is the IP
address we want to connect to.
This is a standard IP address
that always means localhost or
the same computer I'm currently on.
The student@ is the user
we want to log in as.
We want to log in as
student@ this IP address.
Finally, the -p 2222 flag tells
us to connect using port 2222.
When Vagrant set up our virtual machine,
it automatically set up this port on
our local machine to forward
to the virtual machine.
After hitting Enter, you may be asked
an authenticity verification question.
Just hit yes, and then you're asked for
the user's password.
Enter that, and
you'll be logged in as the student.